Today we're praying over day 28,
collecting all the metaphors
and word pictures of holiness in the scripture
that we've studied. There are more of them, but we're collecting the ones that
we've studied, and we're taking them to pray over them
today. Father, we thank you
for the beautiful
multiplicity of pictures you have given us of your work
in our heart, the work of reproducing the character of God
in us. And so thank you for the fuller
and greater cleansing after salvation.
Thank you for the completing of the project of holiness, the
perfecting of the work. Thank you for the
privilege to become what we really are as children of God.
Thank you for the sanctifying work of the Holy
Spirit, the completing of it, the fullness of that sanctifying
work. Thank you for the filling of the Holy Spirit and the
softening of the heart and the cleansing from idols.
Thank you, Lord, for the assurance that our God
accepts the living sacrifice that we offer.
And Lord, we just pray that you would increase our
joy and increase our gladness in these things
until everything that we have is given over
to you. Lord, we want to be full of joy and
happiness. Let the glory of your holiness just
sparkle in our eyes until we see how
desirable it truly is, more valuable than
anything else in all of the world. No
experience, no thing of this earth, no selfish
thing could ever compare to the glory of knowing
your holiness. And so we pray that you would make it real
in our hearts. Lord, your character, your
plan to produce your character in us is so
beautiful. It's just beyond words.
So we rejoice, Lord, in all the ways you've revealed yourself.
So reveal yourself continually to us in Jesus' name.
Let's pray together and continue to seek the Lord.